i just have a big belief in
you know parents having that ability to
be in control of their kids education to
be able to hold the schools accountable
it's unacceptable to have schools that
have you know proficiencies of four
percent six percent
[Music]
can you believe it i'm still here that's
right living inside this tent for 100
days from november 20th to february 28th
bring to you the issues and awareness
that you need to know about the violence
on the south side of chicago but also to
raise as much money as possible to build
a community center on this block that is
much needed called o block it's called o
block because it's named after a young
man named od perry who was shot and
killed the gangs took the o in his name
and started calling it o block we
decided we like the o but we're going to
change the name to opportunity block i
want to thank fox network for giving me
the opportunity to bring to you every
single day my thoughts viewpoints and
opinions on rooftop revelations
and today i'm super excited because we
have someone who is fulfilling our ceo
challenge he flew in today and now he's
with us tonight and i'm excited for him
to be here i want to welcome our guest
tonight dr john radford how you doing
i'm doing great thanks for having me
tonight man we are so thankful for have
you thanks for flying in how's
everything going
it's going well love chicago absolutely
you know i want to start off um with a
question that i always ask everyone
and that is why are you here you know
why why come why fly in and take the ceo
challenge
well i i've seen the videos before in
what you folks are doing at project hood
in creating opportunities for people
um big believers in education and and
how people can
transcend and
get out of the communities or the
situations that they're in
and i i thought you know i saw you about
18 months ago i said to myself hey this
this is great what they're doing i've
got to connect at some point and then i
saw the ceo challenge and i said i've
got no excuse at this point i got to get
up here and learn more and uh and want
to participate absolutely well you know
i'm grateful that you're here and
i want to ask you you know
you're a medical doctor
um but give us a little bit of
background how did you how did you
become a medical doctor i mean did you
always want to be a doctor tell us about
your background your where you grew up
how you grew up sure
well i grew up in a city called
lackawanna in uh just outside of buffalo
lived there first 25 years of my life
been in buffalo the whole time
um
just
wanted to help people and uh so went to
uh college i was the first person
in my uh in my family to go to college
my parents were my dad was an unemployed
steelman and my mom used to type
and uh they really valued education and
so they they sent me to the local
catholic school and then the franciscan
high school and it was an opportunity if
if it weren't for that i wouldn't be
here today
and you know i so i went to university
of buffalo went to residency there did
emergency medicine um ended up
opening urgent care centers uh and and
that's kind of where where i've gotten
here today that's awesome i know we've
talked a little bit about um the
importance of education that's kind of
where i want to focus
uh our whole discussion
how important do you think it is for
kids
growing up in neighborhoods like this
uh to have a good quality education
it's an absolute game game changer for
folks um
i wouldn't be here today if i didn't
have the opportunity there's a lot of
kids in my neighborhood that grew up and
you know whether
they didn't have the same opportunities
some of them um you know frankly they're
they're in jail um
they've they've had a lot of struggles
in life um
and i've been fortunate enough to be
able to send my kids to a private school
and and have seen
you know what what the difference what
the difference is what those
opportunities are
um and i just have a big belief in
you know parents having that ability to
be in control of their kids education to
be able to hold the schools accountable
it's unacceptable to have schools that
have you know proficiencies of four
percent six percent and uh
with the parents involvement and you
talk about school choice and some of
those things i just think ultimately
that's the path out and if you can get
people out
then they can come back and bring other
people out now i think you know the
things that you're doing
um
and the accountability and the no
excuses and those sorts of things
ultimately that's what's gonna be able
to make that long-term change absolutely
i know um both of us have an interest in
a strong interest and a passion in
education and i know one of your
passions and goals is to ultimately
start a school
uh tell us about that a little bit well
i i have a dream at some point uh to
take the the home that i'm in and uh and
transform that into a into a school
where
where we can take the opportunity to
take kids who are in a bad situation
um who
who have
a skill set to be able to thrive if we
can just get them out of that and what
that could look like i've got a lot to
learn about how to do that but that's
you know you look at your different
stages in life of what you want to do
and and to me um in the next phase of my
life that that's what i'd really be
interested in being able to do build a
school give people an opportunity and
then have those folks
you know kind of pay pay it back to
everybody and bring others forward
you know one last question what what is
it that causes you to want to do that i
mean not not everyone especially when
you're successful you got your own
business you're a doctor you're doing
good what makes a person say you know
what
i want to start a school and help some
kids who
who may not have opportunity who may
come from uh sorted backgrounds and or
tough backgrounds what
what what makes you want to do that i
just think everybody deserves a fair
chance you get to a certain point in
life and you know you're successful and
all of those things but you know you
know you eat nice food and you can drive
nice cars but what's that really mean at
the end of the day and yeah i've just
found the the satisfaction i get is
being able to
and i'm sure you know this when you're
able to give and you're able to change
somebody's life and what that would look
like i mean that's there's no greater
gift to be able to do that and
education's huge i mean it's it's really
the
at the end of the day you know my dad
used to tell me look if you know if you
you got to work hard in school you've
got to do that and and if you do that
then you know
life will bring success
and it has for me and i would just like
to be involved with uh you know bringing
others along and it's fun to teach and
mentor absolutely you know that's what
it's all about you know and i want to
thank you for uh
coming here today thank you for sharing
some time and staying all night in this
cold yes
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna talk
a lot and talk about schools talk about
kids talk about creating opportunities
talk more about what project hood is
trying to accomplish and
talk about how we can solve the issues
of the world so
thanks again i appreciate it to all of
you who watch every single day and
listen maybe this is your first day
watching uh tune in to rooftop
revelations every single day right here
on the fox uh app and it will bless you
i promise you all right thank you as i
always say uh
until tomorrow
peace
[Music]
you